Uh, okay, let's go next to, where do we want
to go next?
Let's go next to our caller from the four
to five area code.
Who's calling today from four to five.
Okay.
Hi.
Um, my name is Carl.
Hey Carlton.
Now let me ask you, what kind of device are
we on?
Are we on some kind of headset or speaker
phone?
I'm hooked up to my car right now.
I'm just driving back from work.
Gotcha.
Okay.
It's, it's pretty atrocious, but we'll try
to deal with it.
What's a, what's your question today?
Getting the minimum wage?
I believe it was like seven, 25 to $15 an
hour.
Okay.
Um, like here in here in my state is, and
that's definitely not the minimum wage here
is like 13 something an hour.
But, um, I've noticed a lot of like when,
um, when people try to, um, implement a $15
minimum wage deal, corporations tend to, um,
try to wiggle around it so where they don't
have to pay their employees that wage war
tried to maximize profits.
So my question is, is, um, if we somehow implements
a $15 minimum wage, is that something that
we can do to kind of like make sure inflation
doesn't increase?
Okay.
Well those are two separate questions.
So first question, how, how, so give me an
example of how a corporation would wiggle
around if the minimum wage is 15 an hour,
how do they wiggle around that?
Okay.
So a while back.
Um, what are the airports in my state demand
to have a $15 minimum?
Yep.
That was SEATAC, right?
Yes.
Um, so they said, okay, we'll give you a $15
minimum wage.
But the downside is they cut back on employee
and put in machine.
So way customers can just manually order themselves
right now.
The, the problem with that argument is that
Mcdonald's was going to do that either way
and eventually anyway.
And that those, you know, they don't within
three months of a $15 minimum wage, they don't
develop and deploy those machines in order
to replace employees.
That's been in the works for years, if not
a decade.
And that's going to happen either way.
But that's where I think we probably get to
the same conclusion, which is the $15 minimum
wage is a bandaid in the same sense that a
ubi of $1,000 a month is a bandaid.
It doesn't actually resolve the broader issues
of the inequality that our society creates
coming technological unemployment, that what
needs to be a different relationship between
humans and work.
So I, if, if your argument is a $15 minimum
wage doesn't actually solve the problems inherent
to our economic system, I'm right there with
you.
Okay.
What happened?
What the problem is though is that they're
only in it to maximize profits.
Yes.
And the only way they will maximize profits
increased the prices of their goods.
Well,
to understand is labor only represents a piece
of the total cost of an employee of a company.
Listen, we've addressed this before and there's
so much crazy noise on your line that I'm
going to let you go.
But now we're getting into material we've,
we've already discussed before.
Please call back next time just on a regular
phone line and I think we'll be able to sort
of hear each other, uh, much, much better.
The car, the car Bluetooth stuff is extremely
problematic.
I reserve it only for telemarketers in my
personal life.